- - Madeleine Blais-Morin,
StStéphanie Chouinard et Rafaël
JaJacob. Bonsoir. Quelle journé.
DeDepuis quatre ou cinq jours, n
lele soulignait que font les
prpremiers ministres en parlante
M.M. Ford et Monsieur Trudeau. e
vovous fais écouter Monsieur
TrTrudeau sur la police. On va
JUSTIN TRUDEAU
prpremier ministre du Canada
- - J'ai toujours été extrêmemet
clclair, on ne veut jamais
dédéployer l'armée contre
dedes civils canadiens
etet une population.
C'C'est quelque chose à é éviter
àà t tout prix, c'est une solutn
dede dernier, dernier recours.
EÉvidemment, dans une situation
cocomme ça, on doit êtrtre prêtt
popour toute éventualité.
- - Je pense qu'on a compris que
l'l'option de l'armée n'est pas
susur la table pour l'instant à
momoins que ça dégénèrere encore
plplus. La police doit agir.
- - Oui et ça Justin Trudeau
l'l'avait dit depuis le jour un
quque c'était la police qui devt
réréagir. Il n'était pas au devt
dedes caméras il n'était pas làn
trtrain de dire Bon on va
rereprendre la situation sous
cocontrôlele. Parce que Justin
TrTrudeau n'a plus le choix de e
fafaire. L'économie du Canada et
mamaintenant affecté par le
momouvement des camionneurs par
leles manifestants. Il y a eu ds
mémétastases des manifestants
partout au pays. Quand c'est le
papartenariat commercial des
EÉtats-Unis et du Canada qui est
totouché c'est sûr r que ils dot
agagir. En plus c'est en train e
dodonner des arguments au
prprotectionnisme américain. En
paparlant des manufactures
auautomobiles. C'est exactemente
gegenre de sentiment que le
gogouvernement canadien essaie e
cocontrer depuis des années. Ile
fafaudrait pas qu'un convoi de
cacamionneurs vient tout bousilr
çaça d'un coup.
- - Je voulais faire un tour de
tatable mais pour la clarté de a
didiscussion je vous fais entene
DoDoug Ford qui a installé l'étt
d'd'urgence en Ontario.
- - Stéphanie, c'est vrai que
dedepuis le début au fédéral on
didit que c'est un travail
popolicier mêlala la différencet
quque les deux premiers ministrs
sosont allés devant les caméras
avavec un ton qui était trèss
didifférent de ce qu'on entendat
dedepuis cinq ou six jours.
- - Tout à f fait, la différence
FoFord, la réponse était beaucop
plplus concrètete. On parlait ds
pepermis qui pourraient êtrtre
rérévoqués par le gouvernement,
dedes amendes jusqu'à 1 100 000u
unune peine d'emprisonnement. On
dodonne des pouvoirs
susupplémentaires aux policiers.
EsEst-ce qu'ils seront en mesure
dede faire appliquer ces nouvels
memesures là??
- - Il y a une grosse pression
popour qu'il soit en mesure de e
fafaire. Monsieur Trudeau l'a bn
didit qu'il ne voulait pas envor
l'l'armée.
C'C'est une évidence, le présidt
amaméricain s'est entretenu avec
MoMonsieur Trudeau ce matin qui
lului a dit que ça ne pouvait ps
dudurer.
- - On se parle de pression, il
n'n'y a pas de source de pressin
plplus douloureuse pour un Prine
cacanadien que la Maison-Blanch.
AuAu moins trois risques énormes
popolitiquement pour
l'l'administration de Monsieur
BiBiden. Dès s le début, Joe Bia
ddû f faire face à u une crise a
frfrontièrere sud. La crise font
trtravailler avec le Mexique ça
fafait plus d'un an qu'elle dur.
UnUne administration qui est aux
prprises avec des crises de nate
trtrès s différente mais avec ss
dedeux voisins en mêmeme temps.e
dedeuxièmeme il est évident, onn
paparle depuis tantôt t c'est la
ququestion économique. On parle
d'd'intégration des deux économs
dadans un contexte d'inflation
hihistorique. Encore, les
dedernièreres données du
gogouvernement américain hier pr
rarapport à l l'inflation, des
dodonnées épouvantables. Prés d7
% % par rapport à l l'an dernie.
DoDonc imaginez l'infraction vit
emempirer les problèmemes des js
apapprovisionnements que ça peut
fafaire à l l'inflation. On le ,
PaPatrice, l'inflation c'est le
prproblèmeme politique numéro un
popour le gouvernement américai.
LeLe troisièmeme problèmeme, qui
n'n'était pas dans l'immédiat ms
ququi doit êtrtre envisagé,
prprésentement, avec un taux
d'd'approbation si bas que celui
dede Monsieur Biden la dernièree
chchose dont l'administration
bebesoin c'est que il y a un
momouvement qui prend de l'amplr
cocomme ça aux États-Unis.
- - Hier, Fox News, dès s le dét
cece sont intéressés à c ce con.
PoPour eux, ce sont des patriots
etet Monsieur Trudeau est un
plpleutre et il il y a beaucoup
trtrop de mesures au Canada. Ça
dodonc des effets.
- - Effectivement, pour avoir
reregardé la soirée à F Fox bont
dede temps, on était déjà e en n
dede faire la promotion d'un
évéventuel convoi américain qui
sesera lancé le mois prochain. e
nene dis pas que ça va se produe
mamais dans certains gros réseax
plplus adroits aux États-Unis, n
enen parle. On semble souhaiter
quque ça se produise.
- - Sur l'échiquier canadien, on
lele voit, il y a des franges
d'd'extrêmeme droite là-d-dedane
droite. Il y a la fin de semaine
dedes gens pas nécessairement
imimpliqués dans ces moments-là
mamais qui en ont marre des
memesures. En fait il y a peut-
êêtrtre un changement sociologie
dadans la manifestation mais on
vovoit qu'il y a une droite plus
s's'organiser et faire de
mamanifestations qui font mal au
papays.
- - Quand on voyait juste êtrtre
vovous engager dans un point 13,
jeje ne sentais plus engager mas
plplus nuancé. Il y a quand même
dedes sondages qui montrent une
prproportion des Canadiens qui
sosont favorables au message des
cacamionneurs. En fait il y a un
sosondage Léger cette semaine qi
momontrait qu'environ le tiers s
CaCanadiens qui sont favorablesu
memessage porté par les
cacamionneurs sur la levée des
rerestrictions liées à l la COV-
1919. C'est Trudeau avait commeé
enen disant que le convoi était
dédéjà e en brandissait des drax
raracistes aujourd'hui ne trouvt
plplus nuancer. En disant: ce qi
dadans le convoi et qui est tane
dedes mesures de la COVID-19,
sasachez que nous aussi on est
tatannée. D'une certaine façon a
momontre un peu plus d'empathie
papar rapport à c ce mouvement-.
DeDes gens qui en ont bien assez
dede cette situation-là. . Peute
popour essayer de réduire ce
coconvoi la. Éparpillée grosse
dadans certaines régions du pay.
- - C'est un phénomènene
inintéressant, il y a dedes gros
d'd'extrêmemes droites et de drs
sese sont financées mais qui sot
auau diapason avec une partie de
lala population qui en a marre s
memesures sanitaires.
- - Ce qu'on a l'impression de
vovoir se masser le message
prprincipal qui était porté qui
rérésonne avec une partie
imimportante de la population,
fifinalement ça été une excuse
popour certains groupes et
grgroupuscules d'extrêmeme droie
poporter un message beaucoup pls
dédérangeant, déstabilisant et i
vivise directement l'État de
drdroit. Il faut tenter de faire
lala part des choses. C'est une
cocorde raide assez difficile sr
lalaquelle marchent les
popoliticiens parce qu'on ne vet
papas s'aliéner non plus cette
papartie-là d de la population t
enen répondant quand mêmeme ras-
bobol des citoyens d'Ottawa. Etu
sesecteur économique autour de
WiWindsor. Répondre au cri qui
vivient de l'autre côtété de la
frfrontièrere on se pose la quen
d'd'investir au Canada c'est au
ststade qu'on pense que c'est
l'l'été. Ça aussi c'est une groe
ququestion qui taraude évidemmet
dede Ford. Ce noyau dur-là i ilt
lele voir c'est un enjeu
imimportant.
- - Monsieur Legault Québec
n'n'avait pas été plus présent
dadans les médias avec une crise
cocomme ça Montréal et Québec,
imimaginez. Je vous fais entende
unune question qui a été posée à
MoMonsieur d'Oxford. Samedi
dedernier vous étiez en train de
fafaire de la motoneige à v vote
sasalaire alors qu'Ottawa était
asassiégée.
- - Madeleine et Stéphanie
rarapidement, quand mêmeme ça éé
dudur politiquement ce passage .
OnOn ne l'a pas beaucoup vu.
- - Non et Justin Trudeau non
plplus, tous les deux sont en me
rarattrapage. Je ne sais pas s'l
ététait sur son téléphone 24
heheures sur 24 comme il dit mas
ilil ne le communique pas la
popopulation ça devient problèm.
C'C'était le cas pour Justin
TrTrudeau qui avait l'art de
rerenvoyer la balle aux provincs
ouou à l la ville Lucy est en me
rarattrapage aujourd'hui.
- - C'est comme s'ils étaient
imimpuissants et qu'il ne savait
papas trop quoi dire.
- - Il y a eu un jeu de ping-pog
jujuridictionnel. S'il avait été
prprésent à O Ottawa dès s la pe
mamanifestations qu'il avait prs
unune journée pour aller faire e
lala motoneige à s son chalet, a
auaurait beaucoup mieux passé.
MaMais le fait qu'il était toutà
fafait absent, qui avait vacuum
popolitics à s se fâchcher la
popopulation.
- - La plupart des états ont
lalaissé tomber la plupart des
memesures sanitaires mêmemes les
ététats démocrates. Donc le DeRx
n'n'est pas le mêmeme au Canadal
n'n'y a pas tant de mesures, il
mamanifesterait contre quoi.
- - C'est un peu un cacadeau que
prprésident a reçu de la part ds
mamanifestants. Imaginez, dans e
clclimat américain social et
popolitique ce qu'on aurait pu
avavoir comme situation, comme
dydynamique c'est ce qu'on a
prprésentement Canada. Imaginezn
ininstant. Dans un sens, le
prprésident s'en est bien sorti
mamais en mettant ce qui est
imimportant de mentionner,
- - pour que les gens comprennet
bibien c'est sur l'obligation
vavaccinale, Monsieur Biden s'et
fafait rabrouer par la cour il
vovoulait la mêmeme chose ici.
- - Une fois ça saisi, ce qui et
imimportant de mentionner, une s
plplus grosses histoires par
rarapport à l la pandémie cette
sesemaine aux États-Unis, c'est
unune espècece de cascades
spspectaculaires d'états
dédémocrates multiples car
lelesquelques heures après s l'e
onont annoncé qu'ils allaient
ababolir le port du masque
obobligatoire. C'est importants
cacar les restrictions sont
bebeaucoup moins nombreux et
cocontraignantes aux États-Unisr
ilil en reste quelques unes dans
cecertains états. Surtout
dédémocrates. Maintenant c'est n
sésénateur démocrate un prêtt
l'l'autre qui sort pour abolir s
memesures.
- - Il n'y a plus que la Floride
mamaintenant qui était
cacaricaturale à l l'époque avee
TeTexas.
- - Est-ce que vous croyez lundi
onon va voir des opérations
popolicièreres pour vrai?
- - Justin Trudeau a dit que çaa
irirait de façon graduelle. Pour
çaça et voilà q que ça commence
ququelque part et en fin de
sesemaine avec cette manifestatn
plplus grande qu'on l'attend
OtOttawa, je ne sais pas ça va
cocommencer déjà c cette semainn
n'n'a pas beaucoup de détails.
- - Merci Madeleine, Stéphanie.
- - Une fois débloquée à W Windr
popour les policiers je crois
ququ'on va vouloir surtout
s's'assurer que les enfants et s
fafamilles ne soient pas sur ple
lolorsqu'on commencera à a agire
fafaçon avec plus de force